marty mcfly is the picture of 1980's
california cool no matter what era he's
in
but there's still a lot you might not
know about the young star of back to the
future so we're here to fill you in on
the more obscure details of marty
mcfly's past
present and future michael j fox brought
exactly the right amount of charm and
mischief to the role of marty mcfly in
back to the future making the character
created by writer bob gale and director
robert zemeckis be realistic relatable
and even a little impish
had filmmakers shot the original version
of the movie script however a very
different marty would have ended up on
screen
the first iteration of back to the
future involved marty working for doc
brown
a disgraced physicist who makes a living
bootlegging videos
in one early draft of the script marty
explains that he sweeps out doc brown's
garage in exchange for
fifty dollars a week free beer and
access to his old record collection
initially the time machine wasn't a
delorean but a laser-based chamber
resembling a car wash according to
executive producer steven spielberg
nevertheless marty didn't know it
enabled time travel and actually climbed
into it with a much darker motivation
according to bob gale he thought it was
this thing that was going to shoot off
this big electrical discharge
he was so despondent about how messed up
his life was he was going to commit
suicide
we thought that was a good idea for way
longer than we should have
beloved canadian actor michael j fox is
inextricably associated with the role of
time traveling teenager marty mcfly a
testament to back to the future
co-writer and director robert zemickus's
good instincts
but while fox was his first choice for
the part it turns out that fox wasn't
actually the first actor to portray
marty mcfly
at the time of the film's shooting fox
was starring in the nbc sitcom family
ties which left little time for anything
else in his schedule
so filmmakers went with their second
choice eric stultz an up-and-coming
young actor best known at the time for
the drama mask
a few weeks into filming however a
sinking realization set in for the
filmmakers
stoltz was all wrong for the part that
coupled with fox's sudden availability
led to stoltz's dismissal from back to
the future and the film's production
starting over
more than 30 years after its release the
most lingering question about back to
the future remains
how did a teenage boy who only cares
about cars guitars and girls become best
friends with an old disgraced scientist
it's never explained in any of the
movies but bob gales says that it's
included in the backstory he and robert
zemickus wrote to inform their script
speaking to mental flaws gail explained
for years marty was told that doc brown
was dangerous a crackpot a lunatic
so being a red-blooded american teenage
boy aged 13 or 14 he decided to find out
just why this guy was so dangerous
marty sneaked into doc brown's
laboratory and was fascinated by the
cool stuff he found there
doc caught him and instead of being
upset he was delighted by marty's
interest in his work
after that doc hired marty to be his
assistant
released in october 2015 bob gale helped
co-write a five issue back to the future
comic miniseries
in the first issue gale provided yet
another explanation for how the
time-traveling scientists met the young
guitarist
in the comic the action flashes back to
1982
minor film villain needles plays with a
band called the tabascos but as rock and
roll good times are interrupted when
some fanciful piece of technology called
an intra-sitter tube and his guitar amp
blows out
needles steals marty's guitar and says
he'll only return it if marty brings him
a new intra-sitter tube
marty dutifully hits a local music store
and search for the parks but is informed
that all of its interior sitters happen
to have been purchased by local weirdo
scientist emmett brown
that prompts marty to head to doc
brown's garage to steal what he needs
doc has rigged the space with a unique
security system of traps and puzzles but
marty navigates them with ease
doc brown isn't angry with marty for his
attempted burglary but instead
so impressed that he offers him a job
thus begins their most beautiful
friendship
one that we all know will stand the test
of time
at the outset of back to the future
marty cares about little more than his
girlfriend jennifer parker
jennifer and marty are married by the
time of the events of back to the future
part 2 making them that most romantic
all-american cliche
high school sweethearts who found a
lifetime of love in each other
according to the 2016 comic back to the
future untold tales on alternate
timelines
marty and jennifer first met in the
fourth grade but they weren't
particularly close from the get-go
they reconnect when they're older in
november 1984 but the meeting is ruined
when marty's rival needles pulls up in
his ford f-150 and ass out jennifer
marty is so distracted by needles sweet
ride that he doesn't pay much attention
to jennifer who storms off
however the next day the seeds of their
relationship were planted when jennifer
flirts with marty when she finds him
playing wild gunman at 7-eleven and
flirtatiously nicknames him
clint eastwood in order to meet
publication deadlines writers of film
novelizations often base their stories
on early screenplay drafts
as a result the back to the future
novelization differs wildly from the
movie offering up significant background
detail
on music obsessed marty mcfly the story
begins with marty in school not paying
attention to an educational film because
he's jamming out to something on his
walkman
he's soon summoned to the office for
what's purportedly an emergency phone
call but is actually doc brown asking
him to come to a time machine test at
hill valley mall
when principal strickland confronts him
about the call marty drops his
contraband walkman earning him detention
the administrator then makes an example
of marty by destroying the cassette
player in a woodworking vise
marty ultimately gets the upper hand by
setting off a fire alarm so he can sneak
off to his band's audition for a ymca
dance across
town marty's prank was actually filmed
for the back to the future movie when
eric stultz was still set to star but
the scene ended up going unused in the
finished film
at the end of back to the future marty
uses his musical ability to
inadvertently invent rock and roll by
inspiring chuck berry via a phone call
from the rock pioneer's cousin marvin
you know that new sound you're looking
for well listen to this
and yet when we catch up with marty in
2015 at the start of back to the future
part 2
marty is not the world famous rock star
he seemed fated to become
he's a broken overworked office drone
hampered by a chronic injury suffered in
a long ago car accident
that accident is averted by the end of
back to the future part 3
and in an episode of the back to the
future animated series we see marty's
musical dreams have finally come true
the 1991 episode solar sailors takes
place in the year 2091 where doc
encounters a guy who professionally and
musically impersonates one of the
biggest rock stars of all time
marty mcfly fans of back to the future
have long wondered why george and
lorraine mcfly fail to recognize the
fact that their son marty looks exactly
like calvin klein the guy that met back
in the 50s
bob gale offered a reasonable
explanation to the hollywood reporter in
2020
saying george and lorraine only knew
marty calvin for eight days when they
were 17.
i would ask anyone to think back on
their own high school days and ask
themselves how well they remember a kid
who might have been at their school for
even a semester
however gail and co-writer robert
temecus did include a scene in the first
three drafts of the back to the future
script where george mcfly sees a photo
of marty in 1955 and figures out his son
is a time traveler
they cut this bit choosing instead to
make biff the one who realizes marty can
travel through time
doc brown's delorean is already a pretty
cool car but the final moments of the
first back to the future show that doc
has made some improvements to the
vehicle roads
where we're going we don't need roads
in the fourth issue of the 2016 back to
the future comic book series
it's made clear that doc brown turned
his car into a marvelous flying machine
upon the suggestion of marty mcfly
set in a period before the events of the
first film marty disturbs doc in his
garage who covers up his work in
progress delorean
marty without a car and desperately
unwanted one recognizes the shape
and presumes the doc's top secret
project is a flying car
it's not but doc brown thinks that such
an ambitious project would actually be a
pretty good idea
back in the early 2000s animator justin
roiland made an obscene cartoon short
called the real animated adventures of
doc and marty
the former is a wild-haired scientist
with a delorean-esque time machine who
speaks in an imitation of christopher
lloyd
while the latter is a kid in an orange
puffy vest with a high-pitched squeak of
a voice
in other words there are clear parodies
of doc brown and marty mcfly with little
more than a misspelled name keeping them
from incurring the wrath of the
copyright holders
royland screened this cartoon and others
at channel 101
a regular short film showcase and
competition in los angeles operated by
community creator dan harmon
harmon asked roylan to adapt doc and
marty into a regular more professionally
animated series that ditched the more
overt back to the future connections
so doc became a scientist named rick and
it was a short leap from marty to morty
who became the scientist's grandson
thus rick and morty was born in addition
to portraying marty mcfly and other
various mcfly family members in the back
to the future films michael j fox
reprised his role as marty in the lego
dimensions video game
and in back to the future of the game
playing a future version of marty
but michael j fox isn't the only actor
to ever portray marty mcfly in a
finished production
during the iconic johnny b good sequence
from the first film marty's singing was
handled by mark campbell
a real-life rock frontman while
established voice actors took over the
role for the film's various spin-offs
while fox's voice does appear and back
to the future of the game the primary
version of marty mcfly is portrayed by
actor aj locasio who also lent his voice
to a couple of back to the future theme
talking pinball games
and the marty in the 1990s back to the
future saturday morning cartoon is
actually a voice actor named david
kaufman
who can perform such a great impression
of fox that he also took over for the
actor when his 1998 movie stuart little
was adapted into an animated series
in back to the future marty mcfly
travels back in time to 1955 which just
so happens to be the year a dramatic
romance film called marty was released
which went on to win the academy award
for best picture
but screenwriters bob gale and robert
zemeckis claim that this is all a
coincidence and that marty is actually
named for a production assistant from
the film used cars
both filmmakers worked on that 1980 film
and they're referring to crew member
marty casella
who curiously was not among the back to
the future production staff himself
as for the last name of mcfly zemeck has
just tossed it out as a possibility and
it stuck
while that's a real last name it also
comes from a movie
the 1967 film the honeypot starred cliff
robertson as a character named william
mcfly which back to the future part 3
later revealed is also the name of marty
mcfly's great grandfather
on the other hand it'd just be an
amazing coincidence
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one